coming up next I think you shouldn't get
married unless you're both attracted to
each other otherwise it just won't work
problems come from unattraction if she's
going for money I think she has to
accept the fact that she's chosen money
so she has to also accept that she's
chosen it to be in a situation where
she's going to have to have sex even if
she doesn't want to be like oh she was
cute and I was like she's like 50 pounds
overweight what do you mean you guys are
in London so it's like a little bit
they're not that cute here how many of
you would like to be able I didn't say
expect to be able to would like to be
able to cheat in a relationship like to
explorating I think women just have to
be reasonable a lot of infidelity occurs
in marriages I think you just can't
expect your man to stay faithful if
you're not if you're not put in any
anything out there for him if a man
doesn't sleep with another man's wife
and he's just sleep with another woman
just to get a nut off is that cheating
I'm sorry I'm saying in your ideal world
we have a wife School we're saying to
the Future wives we're saying this is
how much you should expect to have sex
with your husband free to I feel free to
fives is it a week three to five days a
week at least once a day at least
at least once again once a day maybe on
some occasions maybe maybe that their
answers the correct answer but I would
say I don't think there's a number I
believe what these two gentlemen said
earlier as in on demand because on
demand doesn't necessarily mean once a
day it could be once a week it could be
um three times a week it could be once
every two weeks as long as when the guy
wants it he gets it
um I think I think there's no number
it's just about that fulfillment yeah
when when sex becomes routine it does
get a bit dead so yeah on demand works
best for everyone even though on demand
sounds harsh but as I just described it
could mean has to be said okay so so let
me ask you this because like well if
women are watching this you're just
getting intimidated right but um so like
I think this can run into a problem
where your wife is having sex with you
even if she doesn't want to and I think
that that's fair but I think
psychologically it can kind of you know
just like kill the mood completely so
what what is your stance on that because
there are times where you're not going
to be in the mood as a woman or maybe
you're stressed out or you know like
like kids and things like that so like
what level of understanding you know can
a woman expect from a man I guess that
goes both ways yeah yeah I mean don't
starve him you know what I mean like you
gotta you can't because then you can't
get mad if he cheats right yeah well I
think look there's different
expectations how you guys feel about us
putting our way paying bills supporting
in the household or whatever it may be
or you stay things we expect the same
level of stuff when we're talking about
physical intimacy so when you talk about
old all of these things are happening
with kids and family that's fine but
does that mean that if all those things
are happening for me as well I don't get
sex because of that like I still there's
still things I have to commit to well
it's like do you do you want you you can
manufacture genuine desire right so like
my point is this like if you if you are
married probably like to your first
choice because this is probably how that
would work it's like you can't wait to
jump as bones you know what I mean like
you have that and but I think there are
seasons of life where you do have stress
and then so is that really what you
would want it's just like sex even when
she doesn't want it now however I do
think some women fully expect that but
once you get started you do end up
getting in the mood so you know it could
be like a five to ten minute situation
where she's like okay actually I wanted
to have sex the whole time I just didn't
know so I guess like that's what I'm
trying to pick your guys's brains about
do you want a woman to have sex with you
even if she doesn't want to yeah it
should be a duty because at the end of
the day you can't say to a man isn't
allowed to say oh I don't want to pay
the rent this week or I I don't wanna I
don't want to go I don't want to protect
you exactly oh there's a there's a
burglar you can kill her at first it's
fine like your man's not allowed to the
same way I believe a woman's not
actually allowed to if she wants to have
a healthy marriage or relationship it
needs to be like that you say that but
then if you are going to have sex and
she doesn't want to do it then it's just
not going to be the same like me I like
to have a intense session where we're
both enjoying it yeah
and the girl doesn't want to have sex
she's not really going to put in the
effort and there's not going to be that
little oomph and it's not just going to
be enjoyable it's just that once you
bust your nut that's it so I'm curious
just show a hand who would want their
girl to have sex with them even if they
don't want to show her hands oh damn
okay don't be scared oh it's interesting
I'm surprised the overwhelming majority
here that you don't want your girl to
have sex with you if she doesn't want to
because you can feel it look look I I
know women who have been married like 33
years or 18 years but I I associate with
a specific group of wives okay these
women like having sex with their husband
and have like love doing it for decades
but like you you have to have that
genuine desire but that's the problem is
I think like women are ending up in
relationships with men that they're
consenting to they're not attracted to
this guy but he'll do and I think that's
how you end up in a sexless marriage I
think you shouldn't get married unless
you're both attracted to each other
otherwise it just won't work problems
come from unattraction if there's no
attraction guys shouldn't get married no
I think they should get married so they
should get married to ugly girls so I
think one should be married to ones two
should be married to twos right right
that's how it should be and now you say
that yeah but a lot of ugly guys
sometimes tend to have money and they're
getting with these really pretty girls
and then this is a catch-22 and what
you're saying then that bumps them up
and then the girl has to pay for that so
if the guys are three and he's making a
million that might put him up to like a
six sometimes ugly dudes have a game
though you know what I mean like the
majority of the time they do yeah
I think guys don't have nothing they're
just a body and that's it and if she's
going for money I think she has to
accept the fact that she's chosen money
so she has to also accept that she's
chosen it to be in a situation where
she's gonna have to have sex even if she
doesn't want to sure I feel like that's
if you've chosen money then that's your
fault and you have to accept
accountability for that action but if
you want to be in a successful marriage
where it's happy and you're both
attracted to each other go for someone
you're actually attracted to that's how
it should be I think when women put too
much emphasis on a man's looks they're
entering into their masculine it's meant
to be the man that's meant to desire the
woman for her beauty and I think
what's going on now is women are
expecting too much in terms of men's
Beauty and women's standards for beauty
have just dropped social media has
changed women's mindsets yeah but y'all
be gassing up these whales
come on you know come on
some of these fat chicks have this type
of confidence you know it happens to
guys like that like come on my show and
they'll be like oh she was cute and I
was like she's like 50 pounds overweight
what do you mean you know I think it has
a lot to do with it as well and this you
might not agree with me on this but I
feel like lockdown had a lot to do with
men and how we move in this day and age
because a lot of men during lockdown
wasn't able to do what they was doing
before I feel like women took more
control after that in the sense of now I
feel like it's harder for guys to get
girls because of I feel that social
media boosted at that point whereas
before it was there but it wasn't so
important whereas now you have to be a
certain level of caliber in order to get
recognized I think what it is is you
still have eighty percent of the girls
going for the top ten percent of guys
it's always been like that but it's been
more visible now thanks to stuff like
social media right so that's why and
that's what I said earlier about the
reality thing because they live in their
own reality to them every guy is six
foot three every guy earns this amount
of money every guy looks like this Etc
and that thoughts down to other things
because then they also think those kind
of guys usually have a lot of options
therefore they might mess about a little
bit they might cheat whatever so now
they think all guys cheat well not
really you're ignoring eighty percent of
the guys because you're only dealing
with the top 20. so they have a very
skewed view of what guys are there's
guys like we said earlier ugly guys
ugly guys won't matter
like if they're if they substance like
supplement it with other things money
look status etc etc etc right so if but
there's a big big proportion of guys who
aren't doing that and those kind of guys
and completely invisible to girls but do
you know do you know what that's what
I'm saying here I think a man's value is
not determined by how attractive he is I
agree yeah so when when a woman puts all
the emphasis on a man's Beauty
um that's a masculine woman yeah I think
and I think a lot of the things where
you said about the person being like 50
pounds overweight I think a lot of the
time females forget about intention so
that just because the the man might say
yeah cute
he might just be trying to do that oh
yeah yeah I don't want a relationship
with you but we can be better
I did like a rating with this guy and he
he raided like a girl overweight below
above average but the thing is though in
in
real mind
his real mind he's thinking of four but
he's looking but but he wants to do that
and then what happens when we're having
all of these conversations we're
distorted the females break left said
next thing you know it's just a one big
blurred line and I think that when you
mention obviously going for different
looks and because I think you said
something about three for free four for
four five or five because that girl that
makes maybe a four
got the man for an that was a man but
didn't show any intention no but it's
all Matt you see you see when guys are
rating girls seven eight and nines
that's just in their world in the real
world that rating drops by like three
years you guys are in London so it's
like a little bit they're not that cute
here um
a guy will actually over inflate the
rating for a girl depending on his
current
um mindset so if he's been starving for
a while so he's horny a guy whose money
is obviously going to actually think of
the guy as more attractive like I've
I've I'm sure a lot of guys have
experienced it before you're very in the
mood you haven't had it for like a
couple of days or a week or something
and then you start seeing girls who you
wouldn't normally go for as a bit more
attractive and appealing and then after
you bust your knot and you've got post
not Clarity like oh what am I doing
there not feeling already exactly that
is true I have a question about about
cheating
who here would like to be able to cheat
in a relationship raise your hand
like to yeah
how many of you would like to be able I
didn't say expect to be able to would
like to be able to cheat in a
relationship like to I mean the ideal
situation if she loves you she's with
you but you can cheat when you want I'd
like to we had this discussion okay
exercising options whatever you would
like to have sex with other girls
yeah no why why not so my youngest self
would have said yes but it's like if
you're gonna do that then like I feel
that hmm how can I how can I word this
in a way that the comments won't kill me
too late nah what I mean is yeah
like in my younger days cheating was
easy that I'll do it and feel no type of
way but now in my older age it's like
I wouldn't necessarily say that's the
right thing and if if you've got
permission to do it then it's different
but if there's no permission and you're
gonna go out and do it then yeah like
it's for me personally gone sorry I
gotta finish no I was gonna say then I
wouldn't want to do it because I'm not
trying to let my woman down like I want
to build up our relationship and I want
us both to be strong enough and we're in
a happy position where we both love and
trust each other would it be a benefit
to you guys if a girl let you cheat like
if she said you know what what you do I
if I don't know about it I don't care
would that be a benefit to you guys of
course I think most men would love that
yeah definitely that's that's your
standard so so how many of you guys that
raised your hand right if your girl put
out whenever you wanted it would you
keep your hand raised I wouldn't look
what do you mean I wouldn't go out of my
way
okay okay because some guys some guys
like they they need variety no matter
what so I'm just like I'm saying if she
never said no
want the right to cheat you know what I
mean
I mean I would still want the rat to
cheat but
monogamy is not normal though monogamy's
old has been forced upon men most men if
they had their way and they knew there
would be no pushback from women they
would want to have multiple women yeah I
think it's also because women that
aren't Sometimes women look at sex with
their lenses as opposed to ours our lens
is very much like it's it's a sex is a
physical act yeah it's a physical act
right but most women need to have some
sort of emotional connection even if
they don't the first time the second
time and the third time an emotional
connection will build right so we think
about it differently so therefore it
should be treated differently but they
wanted to us to treat it the same as
them but we're not the same as them so
how can we treat it the same time I'll
just take a tired Playboy like I'm good
I'll take a I'll take a retired player
I'm good you get your fill so a question
how many of you think you could be
faithful to a girl long term like you
have it in you
yeah doing it right now okay so everyone
feels like they could but most of you
would want to cheat if you could and it
would be a benefit if a girl let you do
that it'd make her more wifey I mean if
a girl was to say yo like I want to be
in a relationship with you and I don't
mind if you cheat I don't think any man
is going to be upset about that no man
is probably about it for me but it could
be a test at the same time for me she
meant it you think it was a you'd think
it was a trap yeah yeah okay yeah for me
the only reason I would half put my hand
up for that is because if she was to say
to me do you know what you can
number one it would make me not even
want to do it anyway but and then number
two the only thing and maybe it's an ego
thing that would exercise is this girl
rates me you know but still I wouldn't
even want to do it but you really have
got love for me because you would really
let me do it nah you're the one but
still
I wouldn't do it and we all know certain
type of men don't cheat so we yes yeah
we wouldn't want to do that I can't like
you know what happens as well actually
in that scenario it will actually make
her more attractive to you so the reason
why I say that is because when you're
dating and you're dating multiple women
and women know that other women want you
they get more excited by that so when it
comes to a situation like that she knows
that he could go and get other guys but
then that being said if you're being
faithful to her I'm not exercising
options to her she's like I'm the one
who's won but I still the thing is is
competition anxiety in it you need they
need to understand that
they should never think that you can't
get anyone else but them let's let's be
wrong because no woman wants a guy who
no other woman wants it's just not how
it works yeah that's true do I mean like
I'm a faithful man I'll just put that
out there right now I'm a faithful man
but us get attention every now and then
from girls and it was my wife up but she
knows in it like obviously I'm not gonna
do anything because I'm a mad man you
know I'm a man of God and that but
it you know it gets them saying okay I
need to be on point I need to be on game
because people are looking at my man
so I mean and that fact is in a to a lot
of positive through your relationship
she's not going to balloon to the size
of a well if she knows that okay this
guy can walk out and he won't even have
to do anything and he can get someone
else she understands what she has so she
stays on her toes yeah that actually
happened to me so I go back and forth
between like whether or not I'm sexually
jealous but um so my husband's older but
he would tell me I could pull chicks but
I'd never seen it because I'm not a type
of person like I don't really believe
people like that so I was like this fan
said he could I was like I've never seen
it in real life and then one day we went
down to a creek I live in the Midwest
and I just went off to like explore and
I was a little bit pudgy at the time you
know and so I came back three to five
minutes later and there's like this
bubbly 19 year old in a bikini like you
know giggling flipping her hair at him I
was like oh my God and but I never I had
never been put in that position I was
like oh I guess I guess I am kind of a
jealous girl in that way and so I mean
it did inspire me to like you know hit
the gym and take it like cereals like oh
oh like I gotta I gotta keep on toes but
that was my fault because I don't really
feel that way when I know that I'm on
point when I know that I look good it's
like when I'm slipping up where I'm like
oh I'm getting concerned but um to the
cheating thing I think women just have
to be reasonable a lot of infidelity
occurs in marriages I think you just
can't expect your man to stay faithful
if you're not if you're not put in any
anything out there for him you know and
so it's also like I think women lie too
like they think that if they've been
married 18 years they have three kids
that if he cheats that they're okay I'm
Gonna Leave the marriage that might not
be the smartest thing to do that might
be something that you need to go to
couples counseling over or you need to
burn it down according to Modern women
who cares they'll just be screw the kids
no just burn it burn it down 20 years
one night yeah over quick question
though yeah question what is cheating
and the reason why I asked that yeah is
because
if a man has no if a man doesn't sleep
with another man's wife and he's just
sleeping with another woman just to get
a nut off is that cheating
why does that have to go in yeah I feel
like it has to go it matters because it
matters because if you're gonna def if
you're gonna Define cheating I think we
want men to have options right
so if a man just uses a woman just this
is gonna sound bad but for ejaculation
purposes only and he doesn't sleep with
another man's wife
and he comes back to his his main wife
and he does all the things that he's
supposed to do as a husband as a father
or whatever
what's the crime I mean there's two
things one obviously a lot of men say oh
she was better than my hand I've heard
that a lot I've had that on this screen
so that's so men's that's a different
case but I don't see the the I don't
understand the point of why does it have
to not be someone else's wife why does
someone else's relationship impact mine
because at the end of the day if you are
sleeping with someone just for sex and
the other person wants to if she's gonna
cheat she's gonna cheat so it doesn't
really matter if it's another man's wife
or not in that case well historically it
has mattered actually so I mean there's
lots of cultures that have had you know
rules laws legislation about infidelity
and what that looks like and in the past
like men men have had the opportunity to
to cheat from like a Christian context
if it wasn't another man's wife so I
understand what you're saying but it's
like it's 2022 I don't think people are
really putting standards on any type of
cheating it's just like you know
whatever whatever goes down goes down
but I I know what you mean it probably
would be worse if you were you know
being in some other guy's wife well I
don't think you'd want to risk your life
like that so do you think women are
Menchie in the same thing no no but I
think there's reasons that women cheat
that men don't want to hear about
um like you know we're looking for
something we're looking for that
intimacy or that closeness and we might
feel ignored it's just that women have
to understand you know context of the
situation if you're you know a
stay-at-home wife your man's working 60
hours a week yeah you're gonna feel
lonely oh no it doesn't mean that you go
sleep with the neighbor it means that
you try to you try to hit him up when he
comes home from work but not too soon
you got to be quiet first yeah yeah 30
minutes 30 minutes maybe give them 45.
so females are doing it genuinely for a
void uh it depends because you know we
got these city girls so there's
something else I'm just speaking from
like there are times where good women do
end up feeling like compelled to cheat I
know that that sounds weird to you guys
but if it's just like problem after
problem after problem I feel like my
husband doesn't notice me yeah you might
start looking elsewhere for it but I
think women women cheat emotionally but
it's interesting too
um so like I think there's different
standards too because I don't know that
I'd care that much if my husband slept
with another woman I realized oh no like
the internet's gonna be like but you're
a Christian look there's there's like
reasons for this but um I think I would
be offended if this man was accepting
another woman's phone calls and she was
like crying on the phone venting her
emotions to him I'd be like oh no or if
he was like taking her out on dates and
spending a bunch of money I'd be like
this is not right this is unjust how
could you do this to me shooting
emotions like a completely different
thing if I've got one wife and I'm
already doing that for her there is no
way I'm doing that for another one I
mean the entire point is the entire
point of actually doing those things and
actually dealing with a woman's emotions
is because you actually want that woman
in the form of a relationship you want
her to be yours because she's a threat
because you like her personality exactly
and that's that's where that's where it
gets a bit weird because men normally
only cheat physically because they need
a variety it's like food if you eat
lasagna every day for the rest of your
life you might get bored of it so if it
but if you alternate between like
lasagna Pizza like lobster yeah I just
choose not to be in a relationship with
women that are that are hungry I have a
question is there such thing as a woman
doing too much
yeah I've just heard the phrase she does
too much or don't do too much well in
terms of that oh she's just forcing it
like doing the most yeah yeah yeah
so guys stressed so guys point of view
what does that mean I didn't stress or
can I have an example annoying me
no I think I think she means like female
simping
yeah I know but that's that's only
because he he don't wanna so yeah
because if he wanted her if we'd never
do enough if we want you simp as much as
you want like you can you can simp to
the to the moon and back we won't
complain if we want you if we don't want
you stop it I don't feel like you hear
about it so much in relationships like
personally anyway I don't think I've
heard from males now she's doing the
most she's doing too much in a
relationship it's pre that who gets like
talking face so what's what's too much
in the talking situation chip courting
whatever whatever you want to call it in
2022 face
it forcing everything too quickly
especially if you don't really like or
you're just trying to figure things out
it's like when you're dating someone in
the beginning you always say I don't
know what I'm looking for I'm not
looking for anything because if it
doesn't amount to anything it didn't
amount to anything but amounts if if you
say oh yeah I'm looking for something
I'm looking for something and it doesn't
matter I think some somehow you're a
now so you know uh so that's
kind of just guys not wanting to be the
bad guy and it's getting open yeah yeah
because then she can't come to you later
and say you promise something that you
didn't I think like at the at the
talking stage
um a girl
coming up with like so what are we or
where's this going like a couple months
in I think that's doing too much
wait no
okay okay depends how many marks in so
how many months
like um for me I've always said like
four seasons on the road trip
Four Seasons in a road trip yeah that's
how that's how long you kind of need to
that's not that's how long you that's
how long you need to kind of know
someone you know so you talk to a girl
you you do like the situationship thing
for a year if it's going to be a
situationship
um then yeah for a year before you kind
of decide whether you want to lock it
down or not okay roughly what do you
guys think is that uh if if you live
together if if like you if you spend a
lot of time together in each other's
yards and that in each other's places
um to the point where you borderline
living together than less than a year
maybe six months maybe six months so if
she asks you that at six months is it
doing too much no if if we were spending
a lot of time together within in that
six months like sleepovers yeah
so you you mean having sex though not
just no but sleepovers literally sleep
and like waking up with each other like
you know I'm saying seeing seeing each
other's lives and that if it's like that
then six months is okay but if it's not
like that and it's a situationship where
you you don't spend too much time
together like that then yeah you need
you need you need at least a year like
for me I don't really like the phrase
like doing too much and doing them
because as as males I feel sometimes you
have to have a level of like
accountability so we'll say oh we don't
want a girl to have X amount of bodies
whatever it be six seven bodies so in
one hand we're saying this
and then in one hand we're saying when
she wants to take it to the next level r
she's doing too much when she's asking
the question but we full well know if
that she's had x amount of wears
previous to us
we're going to be feeling away I feel
like it it's kind of counterproductive
in a way to say that a female wanting to
know the position that she's in
I feel like it's kind of their rat
because there's so much emphasis on her
body's Rising I think I know what you're
saying it's like you it's like when men
say that they want traditional women but
a traditional woman is not going to be
in a situation step in a situationship
and having premarital sex like if she
actually is traditional so it's like you
you can't you can't really have both
right but I I also think my man's in the
back I think he's just in a city boy
phase you know he'll come around wait no
actually my my question for you because
to me like again as a woman we know we
only have so much time so to me I'm like
if a guy is waiting a year yes that's a
long time here's the thing if you
especially if you want to get married
okay I've been working hard for a long
time
I've built quite a bit
for me to put that on the line for
someone to come in and be in a position
where they could affect that in any way
I have to know that person
for me to let that person in to that
level I have to know that person if I'm
dating that person for a year I believe
with my
decent sense of judgment which I believe
I have after that year I believe I would
have seen enough to say yes or no
if I spend a lot more time with that
person we stay each other stay at each
other's places of residence for let's
say days at a time a week and then and
then a couple days break and so on then
it can be less it can be six months
before I can feel like I re when I feel
like I know you it's not just that you
look good because that's going to go one
day but when I feel like I know you
and I can trust you
and you've got to remember what we oh
sorry so I'm just curious I just want to
get a raise of hands how long do you
want to talk like situationship Court
however you want to call it a girl
before you make it official so I'm going
to say three months
you're good with three months you're
good with three months okay six months
so six months six months
okay six roughly six okay eight months
eight months and then a year
okay so so I it seems like the most
common one it's like six months I think
that was the most hands I feel like six
months is first because that's when you
can that's I feel like that's an ample
amount of time for you to truly get to
know someone if it was three months it's
like three months goes by that that and
and like a lot can happen in in three
months but then a lot more can happen in
six months and if you're spending a lot
of time with each other like he said if
you're staying at X's house and she's
staying at your house and like I feel
like you guys can truly get to know one
another but if it's in a time frame of
three months then you're not gonna know
that person she's not gonna really know
you and it's like I don't feel like the
relationship is it could be long-lasted
because
again you don't know each other I think
it comes down to what you actually mean
by make it official because that some to
to people that's different so for
someone make it official might mean oh
just a relationship or just mutually
sleeping with each other so I mean I'm
exclusively so when I said that I met
like boyfriend girlfriend oh after three
months become yeah yeah yeah yeah three
months is enough for that I think yeah
that's a relationship the reason I feel
like three months because on average if
you look at it like one one day during a
week
one weekend day
over three months that's that's plenty
of time well because I it's like I
understand where the men and the women
are coming from because the woman's
point of view you only have so much time
and so every year of your 20s like that
that's less fertility that you have
every year but from the guy's point of
view you guys are risking more today
than ever before getting married and
committing to women and you get less out
of it so of course you're going to vet
them more yeah but haven't you noticed
that the cultures that talk about having
more and more relationship experience
have the worst marital practices and the
worst of worse rates yes whereas like
there's other cultures where it's like
no there is no relationship experience
you me you're gonna get engaged very
quickly and you'll be married within
three to six months and those those
cultures those marriages do fine so um I
I did want to ask you guys a question by
a show of hands though have you ever met
a woman that you wanted to marry
straight away well just just enjoy ever
ever I've met a woman I've wanted
tomorrow straight away yeah actually
raise up hands
um how long did it take you to know you
wanted to marry her
a week so I'm gonna okay okay I'm gonna
say say within three months
did you know you wanted to marry her
So within okay so so in a way if you
really like the girl you don't need that
much time yeah well I did on that like
my thing was I thought I wanted to and
that true colors came out after like six
months so there was a facade there so
you I didn't the person I thought I was
when it's Amari wasn't actually that
person so that's why which is why which
is why we need double that time yeah I
don't I don't knock the time thing
because with time you can make a more
informed decision and I think what it
goes to show as in if you make a
decision which is more informative time
it benefits the man because time works
in men's favor as opposed to women's
favor and also to add on to that as well
a lot of women have a crazy side and I
feel like in six months she can't hide
her crazy side she's gonna show you her
true colors so that's why I feel like
six months is the perfect amount of time
if it's three months she can hide that
she can act like this girl that you want
because it's all an act but if it's six
months now there's only so long that you
can continue it on four before she ends
up you don't think a woman can hardly
said for six months she could do but if
you spend a lot of time with her then
it's harder for her to do that um I I
don't think that there's any way to go
about this risk-free like some of you
guys are just gonna get unlucky and end
up in relationships with psychos it's
the same thing with women they're like
oh every man is a nurse and says like
you you just might be unlucky I don't
think there's a hundred percent secure
way to go about any of this yeah I don't
think it's gambling sorry sorry gambling
gambling is is not a good thing but if I
was gonna bet on a football match I'd
bet on man united to beat Barnett
I think it actually also comes down to
the kind of dynamic in the relationship
so even if she is crazy if you have an
iron fist it's not going to be that much
of a problem if there is that Dynamic of
utter respect it doesn't matter how
crazy she is she knows she can't come up
to you and start shouting at you or
doing crazy because of the way
you're going to respond so as long as
there is that high level of respect
understanding the man's not going to
take it you have to just demean yourself
and understand that the man is the man
and you are the woman at the end of the
day so and a man's not going to take it
so if you are in that position doesn't
matter how crazy you are you need to
control yourself otherwise is gonna
happen well then she doesn't get the
benefits as well of being in a
relationship as well if she's constantly
constantly a certain type of way that is
exactly why she doesn't get the benefit
it's like we mentioned the
situationships there's a reason that
you're not wife there's a reason you're
not long-term girlfriend and that is
established by your behavior men don't
talk a lot but we understand that we
watch we watch a lot of your actions and
what you do and that's what we base you
on you might say all of this but we're
watching what you're doing and that will
be at the side in fact are if we're
going to take you seriously or not so
question for them for other guys how
long if you had a sister a friend how
long is too long to wait in a
situationship where it's just he doesn't
like you she's never being in a
situationship
okay fine everyone else
to my younger siblings or anything I'll
say at least if you're seeing a guy for
at least a minimum of nine months and he
hasn't made no like no indication that
he wants to make you his girl then yeah
you're just gonna have to keep it moving
otherwise he's going to be played the
fool because he's just running game on
you for me I'd have to I'd have to run
with three months I'd still have to run
with it again and I forget did you say
it takes you three months or it takes
you longer than that yeah three months
oh you said three months okay I would
say six six
I go for eight eight
six six
if I if I had the door off yeah because
it's just interesting because I see the
guy's point of view but I also see the
women's point of view if I had a
daughter or I was speaking to my my
sister or my nieces
in a group I would say to them
um if a guy hasn't committed to you
after a year
um then leave that guy and how long
would you want after the year of the or
three months to a year of a
situationship how long would it take you
guys to marry the girl
ideally would you guys want I think in
this day and age it's hard to even
answer that question because oh wait
actually I'm sorry sorry I have to cut
you off how many want to be married
raise your hand
okay okay so you you are married yeah so
it's crazy
okay so for the guys that actually want
to be married how long would it take you
it depends so if I know that I want to
marry her yeah I could do it immediately
immediately yeah I don't even need any
type if I know everything about her I
know I don't like there's no guesswork I
don't need to I don't need to figure
stuff out if I know everything I need to
know about her I can just get married so
the the three to I think three to six
months was that what you said no I said
three months three months period of of
getting to know her you make her your
girlfriend you can marry her the next
year yeah okay okay ah cool so for me
I'd have to be seeing the girl for at
least five years before I propose and
then after five years I think then I
would propose and then I'd want at least
another two years whilst we're engaged
before we actually get married so we're
looking at seven years
I'm gonna have to agree with that one as
well I'm gonna do it seven years you
know traditional women don't do that
like it's not gonna happen you will end
up with a city girl because she's the
type that's gonna wait Ali I disagree
with you I know I know a lot of girls
that and that in a way honestly they've
made the right guy they have that
genuine desire for and get by it
there's a girl I know that's a virgin
and she's been she's like they're in her
mid-30s with the same dude and she still
she doesn't have a ring no kids and
she's running out of time for the right
guy yeah yeah okay oh like yeah I guess
I guess that's true but I don't know I I
live in a specific area I know a lot of
like Christian wives and husbands and
stuff so my perspective is like a little
bit different so yeah but I wouldn't
recommend it to my daughter I'd be like
come on girl no I agree I mean seven
years how how much do you guys think
weddings cost so the type of wedding I'm
trying to have isn't no wedding that's
just gonna be like that out the way
actually why are we spending 10K in a
wedding I just don't get it like we can
we can get it we can go to the
courthouse tomorrow and that's the and
that's the energy that's that sort of
refreshing but I hate your type of
Scouts but for me from so I said three
months relationship
including the three months though I'd
say two years engagement
and then another three years on top for
that for that for the wedding for me two
and then five so we're together five
years seven years no I said five years
before I propose seven years before I
get married
and then an extra three for a wedding so
five years all together okay five years
seven sorry Paul can I just ask them a
question so why the two years engagement
why so it's a plan so two so two years
to enjoy the relationship to do the
process to see if this is the person you
wanna
have children with because for me if I'm
not going to have children with the
person
then it is there's no point in in
marriage I'm not looking to get married
I have no children but you give another
ring doll
yeah but no that's why I said I said two
years to then get to that stage okay I
said so from obviously I said Fremont
gets a relationship but from the zero to
after two years if I know this person
get engagement so not to not to jump in
the queue so so here's here's where my
one year of getting to know each other
comes in I would I would do all pretty
much most of that within that one year I
would have like for me to be someone's
boyfriend you've got oh I'm not gonna
get married I don't I don't I don't
really believe in marriage yeah it's
it's not impossible for me to get
married but it's not really would you do
it would you do a ceremony and not the
government potentially potentially But
but so in that one year of getting to
know that person and getting to know
each other it covers most of this so
that's so that's the thing like I
wouldn't even be your boyfriend if I
couldn't see you as a mother or a wife
okay I like you now so that so so that's
the that's the thing and and for me I
like we all have our different styles
and then the thing is everything's about
like um that threshold rat so it's just
it's just like cool so now after three
months I want to make you mark my
girlfriend now after the after the
girlfriend stage we're working towards
that now it's you know I mean it's just
like it's different threshold it's not
like I'm putting them through tests I
think just I feel like it why would you
but why would you make her your
girlfriend if you have no intentions of
making her your wife I I would never do
that
that's what that's what I'm saying I
wouldn't it's just about it's just about
time and I'm not gonna make my
girlfriend next day engaged my next day
that that's what I'm saying about the
time skills so so you think you could
identify a wife and you want to have
kids yeah yeah and a mother within three
months
what are you saying like that it's it's
wild no when you say it like that but if
that's
what I'm saying is though if we're
saying that then even six months as well
but what I'm saying is to be in a
relationship with somebody after three
months if you're seeing each other two
times two times a week I personally
don't think that's wild same question
then in a different way so you would be
in a would you be in a relationship with
someone without knowing without feeling
like you can see them as the mother of
your children or your wife
would you be in a relationship with that
person
I don't think I would so you you've so
then what you're saying is you need a
longer period of time like me
that's the point of dating is to see if
you think that that it would be like
viable if you guys are compatible like I
actually what I think like most people
do that are into marriage I think
they'll date for a year I think they'll
get engaged for a year and then after
that year is up I think they'll get
married but that's the point I got
nothing wrong I mean I don't find
anything wrong uh with a long engagement
I think that that makes perfect sense I
think that's fair but a woman wants to
know that she's like off the market I
want to show something off and say hey
it's about communicating realistic time
frames I think that's what it's about if
you just say to her look at the minute
I'm not in a position to get engaged I
don't want to get engaged yet however
within a year year and a half that's and
sticking to it that's the most important
thing I think this is why sometimes
women get um obviously annoyed because
they think your word is bond and it
should be so if you're saying to someone
look like when I met my wife I remember
we was at a wedding and one of her
friends tried to bring me on smoke and
say oh you guys not going to get engaged
yet or whatever but we already had that
conversation and said this is when we're
gonna engage this is sort of time frame
we're looking to get engaged when we're
looking to get mad et cetera Etc but you
need to just be apparent to them and
stick by it so don't lead them on with
oh yeah maybe one day one day but then
again I know to flip for that I know
guys who have literally told their
current girlfriend that they're with
yeah I don't want to marry you so how
long and she still stayed with him and
she still stayed with us
okay guys I want to get through the
actual question so seven years seven
years um you don't believe in marriage
how long for you
I would say a year a year and you could
get married yeah a year oh wow okay just
to change mine I'd say if they're like
you said if there was no ceremony okay
so you would you would do ceremony
okay how long would it take you to get
to a ceremony three years three years
it should have been two years but it was
three three because it covered okay wow
the seven that's no I said oh no no I
wanna know when I get like like like as
the girl you get down the aisle instead
oh my God that would be
I I understand more than anyone like
where the guys are coming from but seven
years is a lot well you guys you guys
know we get smoke for that right like
people start looking at us funny like
you know it's like to be honest I'm not
even sure how many women would even get
married were it not for the female
social pressure
and that's not the woman that you want
to marry the one who's doing it for that
reason exactly no no I know but it's
there it's they look you can't get rid
of it if you're not married by 30 people
look at you funny no matter what so like
that that reality exists so like I
understand why you guys want to wait
yeah I'm just also making you guys aware
of the fact that like we do get looked
at funny the longer that we we hold on
to because people are like you don't
expect anything out of this but you know
why
um I actually I don't know why I just
know that girls do it there's a funny
joke in my community as well where the
girl is getting married to have the big
wedding and then she the joke is oh but
now she has to sleep with the husband as
well like oh suddenly the guy I'm
marrying wants to do more than cuddle
right yeah I understand but I got I got
married like super low budget um just
because we had we were trying to get
done but I had like my reception
of your opponent before you got married
before I got married I think we this is
hard uh I think we were together for a
year and a half I think so that was when
we got married
mm-hmm
let's be I think I think people know
whether their partner is marriage
material quite early I'll say around
around six months to a year I think
people have made up their mind like you
know what
I can I'll take a bet on this one or
I'll pass on this one I'm sorry so I
personally think if we're gonna take
that into account
the age of the woman how many kids you
want
I don't see the point of waiting seven
years if we meet a woman at 25 what
you're gonna wait five years so you're
gonna wait five years to find out if
she's the one seven years to propose but
she's 32 at that time
I'd actually also add most men have a
like a checklist in their head of what
they want their wife to like they have
certain things about their wife and they
want to make sure she has it doesn't
take that long to figure it out yeah
there's certain things you want you can
figure them out within three to six
months you can figure them out like if
you have literal checklists in your mind
does she do this can she do that you can
figure them out quickly you can
literally ask her you can ask questions
you can figure them out after time
things do show it doesn't take that long
to figure out your checklist and if you
if everything is checked on your
checklist I have no problem immediately
marrying because then I know I found the
one as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible